alexander dugan listening to tributes to
his daughter
daria dugina was killed on saturday in a
car bomb attack near moscow her father
says she recently told him she felt like
a warrior
the price that we have to pay can be
justified by only one thing the highest
achievement victory she lived in the
name of victory and she died in the name
of victory our russian victory our truth
our orthodoxy our country and our empire
daria dugina was 29 and worked as a
commentator on a nationalist russian
television channel just two days after
the attack russia's federal security
service or fsb named a ukrainian woman
as the perpetrator it said she'd rented
an apartment in the same building as
dugina
ukraine has said it does not resort to
terror tactics blaming russia's own
government or security apparatus it
typically takes months or even years or
often never
for uh political murders to be solved
and yet uh the fsb the russian security
service claims to have done this in a
matter of hours and i think everyone
looking at the kind of details they're
providing
you come to the conclusion there's
nothing credible about the story that
they have put together
how much influence dugan has over
president vladimir putin has been the
subject of speculation inside and
outside russia
what's clear is he and his daughter
expressed far-right nationalist views in
public and strongly supported the
invasion of ukraine they'd both been
placed on international sanctions lists
for spreading misinformation
witnesses say alexander dugan decided at
the last minute to travel in a different
vehicle from his daughter
social media footage showed him looking
on with the car still in flames
president putin has never publicly
supported him but he's called the car
bomb evil and posthumously awarded
dugina the order of courage medal nadeem
baba al-jazeera